Carved into a sandstone cliff on the edge
of a bygone river,  a hunter draws his bow for the kill.
He is accompanied by thirteen dogs,
each with their own markings, two with lines running
from their necks to the man’s waist.
A new study reveals these engravings may date
back more than 9,000 years, making them the
earliest depictions of dogs in the archaeological record.
The carvings are from northwestern Saudi Arabia
where archaeologists have catalogued more
than 1400 rock art panels
containing nearly 7000 animals and humans
Settlers began entering this part of Saudi Arabia
about 10,000 years ago.
Early engravings of women,
switched to scenes of cattle, sheep and goats
when the region’s hunter-gatherers became herders
around 7000 to 8000 years ago.
In between these eras are the early hunting dogs -
medium-sized, with pricked up ears,
short snouts, and curled tails—
hallmarks of domestic canines.
All of the dogs look a lot like the Canaan
dog,
a largely feral breed that has called
the desert home for thousands of years,
an indication that these ancient people were
breeding dogs adapted for hunting in the desert.
Researchers found one aspect of these carvings
to be especially striking - the leashes.
This would have been early days for any type of dog,
as the animal may have been first
domesticated as recently as 15,000 years ago
Until now, the earliest evidence for such restraints
came from a wall painting in Egypt
dated to about 5500 years ago
Arabian hunters may have used the leashes
to keep valuable dogs close and protected,
or they could have been a way to train new dogs.
Or the lines might not be leashes at all,
but instead be just a symbolic depiction of
the bond between humans and dogs
and there is still some doubt
about the dating of engravings.
It’s possible that the engravings were
made more recently, and that the artists were just
representing scenes from their cultural past.
To confirm the timing, scientists will need
to link the images to a well-dated archaeological
site, a difficult task in a region
with a spotty archaeological record.
If these engravings do indeed prove to be
as old as they seem,
they would offer a fascinating insight
into how these ancient hunter-gatherers
used the bond between man and dog
to brave the harsh climate of the Arabian Desert.